These ladies and gentlemen
, we respectfully
greet you
with my
most
heartfelt feelings.  After the start of the war
,
a video products Cooperative
would not be at the meeting held in Brussels,
nice
how it met for the 3rd time.
Should we show this support with our vision and what we say is this for our attempts to stop the
destruction and tears,
the police are being defeated in order to state in the first session, with the message
, from the beginning of the old process, with the
word President Putin, whom
you know recently.
One of Turkey's results, we took the
stone that can speak with beautiful photos,
we did not share it
, it was welcomed again.
Is it for export?
It's red. This very fast research has
been completed, we are filling our water.
While
part of our fathers, did he play because we accepted from the documents that
the international public thought about the name the most, at the summit, that the international public thought about the name.
The murderer who tried to
change Iqbal over the lives and blood of the innocent,
today Comb your hair,
we have the six-
ring? What
history has shown us that this kind of
later returned as deadly threats,
we are the
first
and
their recklessness looks like
an
Army
By the way, it's in English that we need to get rid of it
, so this
[Music]
At least Bud Restaurant
will do Ford, will you
bring the perpetrators of terrorist financing and militant recruitment
[Music]
Membership applications,
then the real love
signed memorandum of understanding
understood Turkey's sensitivities, all as the same sign
Abidin Of course, these three branches are the
starting station, the invitation
is especially wrong
. On the contrary
, it is strange to say that the shortest number of the most [Music] would work in the rankings of interest in busan,
and
after the difficult process,
I don't know.
As the embargo in the defense industry area of Waikiki alway
involves going to the shops at a little faste
pace, you
will put the work of this cooperation into it for the first time, and the siste
in defense industry issues Never national exist
ng overflow pract
ces  Open
the ip Kader application for Turkey
[Music]
and the winner is at the same time
there is hatred and there is
first of all we will attend this we are neighbors every time we are neighbors every
time in peace
and security
meetings
this time the President is working and acid is on the money of the
Austrian federal chancellor
So you Mesut  I am the head of the by-bye government
m
The fastest seat of the alliance, which has been a NATO member for
2070 years,
Mustafa, I slept a lot with the commissions for a hundred paragraphs, too much troubles in front of
Coşkun.
Is it really too organized Now
[Music]
Subscribe
Ben 10 James Price from Avcı Zirve
English
Is it the weekend or is it light on the face,
while Bekir's phone is
not going to continue Diplomacy mining?
we
will work in this business I think we are in this much region
through these ships o
Hello everyone  ba wonder cotton size News
Agency quickly its various layers Ok
sir, it was too much if you just know that the flag has met with your
picture about the ef16s in the new press conference
and that you have supported this sale and
its approval from the congress,
if you know correctly that the neighborhood is high.
Tell me now, as I
promised you will work with the congress on this issue
.  There is an air at the beginning of the countries,
if Turkey's Ali is in the congress,
we approve this sale,
share your hand with the subject, in which one
, this is Sweden and Finland as the second, and let's
take care of the front, the parliaments will
answer the
colt immediately.  Of course,
Mr. President, and he
will take the
steps
he
can.  I have not taken the line by holding talks with the
republicans so that we will send our meats for my sake.
They also have a deep view on the subject.
According to
the agreement made, how will this be
implemented since I left
Turkey?
There are some steps that Turkey wants
to take
from prestigious Finland.  We
don't need the Turk anyway, so
we have a jeep made of ice in the parliament
, I slept after it didn't pass, this
process, and Finland
fulfills the duties as well.
If not, I was
able to enter
very quickly
, because of the legal regulations of terrorist organizations 10
this A Haber Rüya Akkuş Efendi
, if it continues in Sweden and Finland,
as a move against the sea. Actually, how
new kindergartens were started,
he earned the wrongs of all these, a counter-explanation
came, his address evaluated this politically
and on the one hand  You just
said that Mr. Joe had made a statement
here, he used very harsh words
against his presence in Europe, and you even
said
that
we are strengthening ourselves
against his presence in Europe.  If we think about
how to withdraw 2-3 young people after these harsh statements and decisions Thank
you, the leaders before you also made statements
like that, let's say, Russia Ali, let's say the flag was a little more.
a also
Therefore, we
entered the fight over the policies of balance
, and even if it is not pure and
necessary Industry
energy
natural gas natural
gas
also follow the energy process that is currently loading on a
win-win basis, this
AK Party inspects the dungeon
, let's talk once again  Are
you
this, you will give it here again
Hypo wonder liquid,
subscribe
Well, let's see if you can buy it from my language,
wow, hungry, you know,
do you all
have spinach, where are
you?  you
do the balance polyclinic here
, well run according to Diplomatic conditions,
all the table will be much more useful
peyss I'm getting it Yes it's good.
According to this,
it's much better.
Elazig
president is an alliance member at the summit  i Good morning
dear non-military Of course,
on the
subject of structuring Atatürk's Islands, and on the other hand, it was
useful in your conversation that the United States of America had
a speech about superiors in
Greece.  Look at everyone in our
understanding of politics and the trouble never
sleeps, look what interest is this and lately
Especially he
sneezed after the meal I gave him in Istanbul or it's
like iron in my life there has
never been a relationship between us
Yuh let's have a double
The speech in which even the Senate of the Republic
made a match in America and the ability to say that this is the best
moment of ours was completely reversed after this week,
not only that,
but not only that,
but also go and go and
have special visits to these places with both Mother Bakery Safa Adalar Islets Dogan and the other
with his
visit  In
an effort to go to a halt, this is a victory. These Islands are
islets.
According to
the Treaty of Lausanne, there is Design. In
short, when there are incidents of
establishing a base in the American bill, such as with guns, the
answer is
to look at the beginning.
o Sultan Akdoğan ATV Sir,
Before the summit, I would like to ask a little question to politics.
Before the summit,
the characteristics of the opposition are always
towards a criticism as to why we oppose our health against Sweden and Finland.
You just underline it.
The memorandum signed on Tuesday
recommends Turkey's fight against terrorism concrete R  You
said that we received solid guarantees, it echoed in the
opposition front in Turkey
, and it was criticized as a step back and
no concessions
came to you.
As it
aroused the most interest here, we welcome all of you
to the taxis at the Erler point,
what is it, this is the
information to us.
supporters of tıtsım, they
are in Portugal at the moment,
but unfortunately, the opposition is in this situation
.
I thought about opening up, they were
in some hundred men about the issue of the terrorist who sold
it to him in 61.  Ankara chief artist
Discussions are continuing in this context, this year
Interior Minister Mevlüt Çavuşoğlu
plays accessible American loops, son's
daughter boom Arda has made interviews. Waiting for him,
military, political, judicial and funny
files are discussed in depth here.
Cover Mina goes up, but our
meeting and this is my head
removed in Turkey.
Thank
you.
If it doesn't come true,
then I have what is in the contract, we
will fulfill it, and
you promise us that you will give it to you bro, you promise us that you
will drive eggs seriously, milk laws pink, it is
good that your
videos
will fulfill the promise given personal
agreement program politics iftar time
foreign policy now
And then, in Turkey,
please, is
this your word?
is the account that needs to be done the
most, it's left to be Heh
and I'm both of us Let's kick Castrol
anyway 3
pieces to the square the People Who
Who says that I don't have that
thing iPhone Plus count is requested
Bayram  how
free he should question
himself first, our citizens have to question himself,
first of all, our
citizens
are now Diyarbakır Mothers mind
is in front of all of them for 1100 days. Their children are crazy.
Mothers
look at their children. 12 years old 13 years old 14
years old more kidnapped
.  What were
we waiting for?
your freedom is
up to my area of freedom If you continue this with a humane understanding, sex videos
here is a
tate of affairs in Turkey toda
.  what do you say?
I'm full of you,
your body is full, it's all
dangerous  will give us  Sooner or later,
they will implement the promise and they are
hungry in Yazıkaya. Namet So
, will the colors of your pain fulfill the promise,
this okey
subscribe,
God mercy slows down pure slowing each time
Space Agency God don't talk too much
Diplomacy Elif has me for her pasta and it's
a gas for you dough lift Ferro Que
Tu femen'den juice
[Music] is
completely
for this
effective Hello
how
of
Bora renegade hard microscope Sedat came out
Focus Angry nasis Fire Thank you
Thank you
but first of all I
have moved too much for a service.
I have a political background of 40 years. From
my mayor to prime minister
how much last minute to get out or to Syria at the
moment in
reality using party organizations
in
politics
If you are at peace I'm past
that old video in the Park and there is a fact
that our relations continue in the form of a birthday, which allows you from the moment you came to power in Ukraine when you were in the apartment with your ex.
If we are going to do it,
one of the most important steps is
Çubuk, with its representatives, Russian Federation
onl.  we talked to the bee, they
started a new process
,
continue by accelerating, this
is a time of destruction in a world where there is a grain crisis
So
you and Russia both
can make the biggest numbers that are being dealt with 8kam I believe
that right now in Samsun kitchen is not
suffering Wheat and barley in the
circle here
Selamunaleyküm
and about
that international in Turkey
We will not do an operation that the community will not understand
Aysun, I will
not stay in the village,
they will understand the operation is out
Turkey Today or
how many puppies my mother is watching
Ayvacık is looking honey I didn't say
this is
Spain First of all, I am sure
you are playing very sincerely
I am
sure at the most sensitive period Goodbye
you know Klikıt Mahallesi  Let's
settle the dormitories in our country Chucky stopped the other one to
the partners in the middle what was
Spain didn't take overtime I'm their
battery So it's standing So on
behalf of my nation On behalf of my state
Especially
we took a step
with Spain and built the ship with Spain
right now  And our Anatolian aircraft carrier, which was
launched, I think so.
Now, it will start its mother voyages, because now these
weapons will sit and eat, and the
helicopters are
the captain of a different aircraft carrier. Apart from that
, our current one, 15
billion dollars, is the light trade volume due to Aşkın Stream.
Our goal is
to
save it by $20 billion this week If you're the one on this subject, your statesmanship
will be important, especially if you are playing the house and have to
support it on the occasion of the meeting, the
most heartfelt time King Pop
This Sunday, you're at home.
What's more important of both,
he
subscribes to the blind flag,
but from politics Like this  Does something happen?
democrats republic  Meatmakers need
a certain support from both sides
Despite all this,
I am sure of their cleanliness. I believe this. I
have already explained this here.
Am I right
away, a result close to our friendship and solidarity is that Isparta has made a result that is close to our friendship
and that Sheikh Efendi is doing well with water and those girls are very
good with the strength that is lacking in age.  something
Yes, now that you are reading the text,
it will deal with
or will not give it. Of course,
what we understand is important what we understand in
speeches in important meetings, and in
this text, Sibel does not promise that you will give us by updating Sweden and 73 people, we will
now follow this text through this text
.  Will I give our decision
tomorrow? Especially if
these judicial systems
support terrorism
, they are not at home.
ert Anyway,
I hope that
Finland and Sweden will
do what is
necessary.
After seeing it, we are not interested in coming,
but say
this: Greece, which violated our airspace 147 times, has to give an account for this. You
will have to say
hello to it 147 times.
Ozan and Paris agreements went wrong,
Mom, let them read these agreements too
, take your steps accordingly O
hehe
Yes Well, what are you doing
OK, let's take a trip, please Enes is
not a team
e and both English  ly
Turkey Afghanistan
subscribe
and
fight against terrorism in Afghanistan
You know before. We
had close soldiers here again Klas and his
grade
, together with the
United States, we fought
a serious struggle here as a coalition customer.
With the desire of your
brother to operate the airport,
we can take it on top of being a person as much as we are, even in the
United Arab Emirates.
we will do Yes and
subscribe
this
I am talking Aslan Yiğitler additional
like to a to Ask question concerning the
definition of police mi causes The World
Point was listened in return Vital
Yuvar Park every program video YouTube
Sub follow burial  ition notaras indir Fark
above teeth System Which is not Access
The
Reason Why problem tripod You
Know Your dad
Emre finland will How to extend terrorist
ve
and the definition and Finish and
Swedish
pikeyi terrorist organization Android
last.fm
ya Ben too Wow co1 Wow disobey  Care
not Who died people that up
rhymes rhymes rhymes touch it
[Music] at
a terrorist
point
Don't trust him either,
show him the hernia, 10,
together with these documents,
our works and
the documents he gave
,
and our judicial bodies
do not demand them anyway
.  she could log out
subscribe
shealso
subscribe she  l
subscribe